joining us now to give voice to what's
going on in cleveland from all cleveland
browns fans is a cleveland browns senior
media broadcaster and also the co-host
of cleveland browns daily and also the
former co-host of fantasy football live
with ashton kutcher and this guy named
tj jefferson
nathan zeguro here on the rich eisen
show how are you nathan i'm doing great
richard it is an honor to be on with you
and yes reconnect with my good friend tj
well t everybody knows tj tj you know
everybody as well you know i've been
around i've been around these streets
rich i know you have all right nathan uh
ner what do you what are you how do you
turn brown's fans going into tonight's
game what do you got for me on that well
i think we're on the precipice rich and
you've done a very good job on your show
kind of summarizing the state of affairs
and also that look case keenum was
indeed brought here to play very well
and i loved what he said in this press
conference somebody said you know how do
you get ready on a short week and he
says you don't have to get ready when
you already are ready and so he's been
ready for this opportunity for a long
time and so i think brown's fans know
that look we are banged up we're three
and three we're coming off of uh a
beating at the hands of the arizona
cardinals and this is a very very
important game before you get two
divisional games coming up and it's one
that feels you don't want to use the
term must win there's still 11 games
left in the season but this is an
important game and one that they've got
to do what good teams do and find a way
to win well i just feel like i've been
caping for baker mayfield quite a bit
from this chair nathan tell me it's
worth it i feel like it is
but um you know
this is a guy last year down the stretch
20 touchdowns only two interceptions i
think in his one healthy game this year
which is all he's had he was excellent
against the kansas city chiefs the
browns were a dominant offense in that
game he's had a great game obviously
against the chargers as well but this
injury has affected him but what baker
mayfield can do when he is healthy is
operate this offense very effectively
he's got a much stronger arm than people
realize he can throw it to all levels of
the field with great accuracy and he is
the guy that has turned things around
here and i think you've made a lot of
good points one that case should play
well and that doesn't change anything
about baker mayfield being the starting
quarterback agree with that completely
and that you know you look relative to
what's happened here in the past and
i've been rich with this team since the
2013 season so i've seen some lows and
the highs that i've seen have all been
associated with baker mayfield and what
he's brought to this football team so i
think that your standing for baker is
definitely
a smart thing to do and in the context
of this offense run by kevin stefanski
he's an excellent trigger man for this
game plan for this town and he really
kind of embodies i think the toughness
of this city what's been with the
defense though that's that's been my
point here as well nathan uh nathan
segura cleveland brown senior media
broadcaster co-host of cleveland browns
daily here in the rich eisen show to me
the defense they they they coughed up 33
to kansas city which obviously
uh back in week one and no matter what
week of the nfl season you can
understand that the chargers sliced them
up um and now you saw what arizona did
those are three teams that you're
talking about being elite and now you
a lot everyone throws that on baker like
you should have overcome that since
you're the elite quarterback we want you
to be first overall overlooking the rest
of the fact that uh the defense has been
um what's the word for it i guess is
substandard compared to what we were
expecting from them nathan it has been
what i would say jekyll and hyde when
the defense has been good in the browns
three wins the defense has given up 11.3
points and 201.3 total yards per game
and i regretted one was against houston
one was justin fields first start and
that was a historic performance actually
the best defensive performance in the 75
year history of the cleveland browns but
when you go to minnesota and shut down
the vikings and hold them to seven
points in their building that was a
great performance the problem is as you
pointed out in the three losses against
elite offenses they're giving up 39
points and 414 yards of total offense
per game this is a game rich that i feel
is on the shoulders of the defense you
don't have baker you don't have nick
chubb you don't have kareem hunt it
looks unlikely that you will have odell
beckham jr it looks unlikely that you
will have both of your starting tackles
you could get jarvis back you could get
one of those tackles but pretty much on
defense other than jeremiah wu su cormo
you've got everybody you've got miles
you got the guy that you paid a lot of
money to up front genevieve and clown
he's had a very nice season you got tech
mckinley you've got malik jackson malik
mcdowell you brought in anthony walker
jr you paid john johnson a lot of money
on the back and you got denzel greedy's
healthy greg newsome is healthy so you
are healthy on defense against the team
that has been struggling on offense your
strength as a defense is your ability to
get home with four the denver broncos
weakness on offense is their ability to
deal with four-man pressures that's
where teddy has struggled that's where
their line has struggled this one's on
the defense and rich the defense has not
been what it is supposed to be yet
i still say it's a lot of moving pieces
a lot of new faces if we were talking in
november which by the way is not that
far away i'd be more concerned but
tonight is a night that i feel like this
defense must show up all right the stage
is set for thursday night football all
right nathan uh we we've known tj for
quite some time you go way back with him
uh how does his prices right performance
sit with you nathan zagar
how does he know
i feel like tj
whenever he gets into a room kaboom look
who stepped into the room tj jefferson
he kind of takes over it's captivating i
feel that tj's performance was good but
i expect completely great
greatness and i expect honestly tj to go
on prices right as a contestant and
leave as the host
but that was the problem you tried tj
that was your problem that's what you
tried i was i was trying to step in for
drew when he had a sick day or something
he was trying to step in but i thought
that you know that's how much i believe
in tj because he is as you mentioned
who doesn't know tj he's the mayor of
not only southern california frankly
he's the mayor of the country his reach
extends all the way to the great state
of pennsylvania all the way to the
shores of the east coast new york city
down into texas with his beloved cowboys
i mean
he's a man of the people
i could have said it better nate i could
not have said it better brother how much
are you paying nate like come on that's
my man in him that's my man right here
yeah we go deep we go deep in his
wrestling knowledge is also i would say
second to none so he's a man of great uh
of diversity of thought multi-talented
multifaceted i agree that's why he's
with you now
i appreciate you saying that that's why
it was shocking all of us here that he
was part of the uh the double over on
that day
which which is so disappointing to every
viewer of price is right nobody wants it
nobody wants it neither did i i didn't
want it i know that hey nathan uh good
good luck tonight with the game and uh
uh we'll chat down the line yeah and i
just want you to know rich i've passed
on that even though we don't have our
starting running backs to run the ball
earnest can catch it felton can catch it
we're maybe going to dig into the larry
david playbook here just throw it to the
running back nobody
hey he said he could he could coordinate
the defense just give him a time to just
learn the personnel and he'll take it
over
you know it's so good so good what a
pleasure to be out with you rich really
appreciate it right back at you nathan
segura brother uh from uh espn cleveland
and cleveland brown's daily co-host
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here